what actually is hugging face it's a
leading open platform for AI Builders
democratizing good machine learning but
what does that actually mean there are
three pillars models data sets and
spaces models are the thing that
actually do the AI we host hundreds of
thousands of models including ones from
major companies like Google Microsoft
and meta as well as research
institutions like Stanford and open
source communities like alther AI then
there's data sets openly accessible data
used to train the models and finally
spaces which let you easily demo and
showcase models a recent example being
illusion diffusion all of these pillars
together are combined with open- Source
libraries like Transformers diffusers
and accelerate making it easy to build
share and use the latest AI models all
of this is free but if you need more
compute or help deploying your own
models we have that too so if you want
to be involved go to hf.com